[Music]
oh
to become the god of the new world
do what you wish with humanity bend them
to your omnipotence
it's an ideology that kira failed to
bring about but one that perhaps could
eventually be born once again
should in the wise words of luke himself
another interesting human be chosen
following a troubled youth named mirai
upon graduating middle school he jumps
off of a building in an attempt to
commit suicide
only to find himself saved by an angel
named nass
and afterwards unexpectedly pitted
against 12 other candidates who have all
been chosen by angels like himself
to become the next god
yep god of earth and everything on it he
who creates and presides over all a
responsibility that is in the world of
platinum end to be left in the hands of
one of 13 random suicidal japanese
people
with wings on his back and the ability
to make anyone fall in love with him in
one hand and the power to instantly kill
someone in the other it is up to mirai
how he chooses to wield this immense
power
and ultimately decide the fate of all of
humanity
now beginning this manga it is almost
impossible not to draw comparisons to
other famous works like future diary
which has an almost identical initial
concept and a connection that is even
more evident whether it was purposeful
or not in the main character's name
mirai being the japanese term for future
they're both battle royales to determine
the god of time and space
and platinum end also reminds me a lot
of iniyoshiki a series that i've loved
ever since i watched it airing in 2017.
all of these stories show how complete
strangers people of various beliefs
perhaps that the wealthy should rule
over all or that no human should hate
one another how these people separately
act once given unrivaled power
we see in inuyashiki how this leads to
both chaos and heroism bringing out the
absolute worst in people or the absolute
best
this kind of story begs the question of
how power is defined when wielded in
different hands
it naturally gives rise to questions
about the greater good of humanity and
just how far humans will go to see their
ideas come to fruition
should they have the means to do so
it's always an interesting concept to me
and it's one that most of all tugumi oba
and takeshi obata's first work death
note touched upon significantly
and you can see the legacy of death note
its philosophical themes its
storytelling even its characters quite
evidently in their third work which is
of course platinum end
in a way platinum end is the fulfillment
of death note's last unanswered question
what would happen if a god of the new
world truly were to appear
this underlying theme behind platinum
ends the basis from which it is built
upon is an idea that to me is best
defined in duke's single word
[Music]
takashi obata and tsukumi oba are
arguably one of the most famous duos in
the manga industry not only because of
their two internationally recognized
manga death note and bakuman both of
which are held in very high esteem
everywhere you go
but also because of their rather
peculiar habits
oba's actual identity tsukumi oba being
a pen name of course
is still a closely guarded secret to
this day something that many manga
authors don't actually do nowadays
and along with having very unique traits
like collecting teapots and holding
their knees on a chair the writer
themself is likely a direct source of
inspiration for their famously eccentric
character l
on top of this despite the close-knit
relationship between writer and artist
that was explored in their own manga
bakuman the actual artist obata and
writer oba were reported to rarely if
ever actually work together during the
three-year run of death note instead all
messages and work being related through
their editor
but instead of being reasoned to believe
they don't like each other's presence it
is likely the complete opposite
in that they have such firm clad trust
in each other's respective abilities
that they have no need to directly
collaborate
obba is said to just give brief
descriptions of characters or leave
messages for background art as simple as
quote-unquote abandoned building and
leaves almost all of the visual creative
effort to obata
it's a level of trust that evidently
pays off not only in the absolutely
stunning art of obata both in character
design and backgrounds
but also in the broader sense of things
with of course the renowned success of
death note and bakuman both completely
different types of stories as well one
focusing on a dark and psychological
tale of mystery and cat and mouse while
the other follows the light-hearted but
realistic story of two mangakas pursuing
fame and romance
oba and obata's decorated track record
demonstrates that the duo are capable of
stories and art on both ends of the vast
spectrum of genres within manga and thus
whatever their next work would be if one
were to come
was highly anticipated regardless of
what it was about
and after a three year break following
bakuman the pair once again returned to
the pages of weekly shonen jump
introducing the world to their next work
platinum end
a manga that has after 58 chapters and
approximately five years of publication
finally ended this past january and has
already given rise to an anime
adaptation coming later this year
death note became famous for a number of
reasons
first it was one of the best mystery and
psychological manga of the time and of
all time frankly as it is still one of
the best to this day in both manga and
anime the latter of which certainly
popularized it internationally
it was especially notable as well at the
time because such a dark and gritty
manga was accepted into shonen jump a
feat that the author oba themself could
barely believe at the time as they said
it did not fit with jump
but as a result of being in weekly
shonen jump because death note was
directed towards a younger audience for
the sake of focusing on pure
entertainment oba naturally expected the
young to push back on the more
meaningful and deep ideologies imposed
in the manga the creator specifically
noted some of these ideologies such as
debates about whether light is good or
evil
life and death and the merits of our
internet society
and the reason i mention all of these
aspects individually on top of it being
a mystery psychological manga
is because all of these are integral
parts of platinum end as well
granted the story doesn't just of course
copy light yagami in fact the main
character is probably the furthest you
can ever be from light
if light is willing to get his hands
dirty for his ultimate purpose to become
the god of the new world
mirai is someone who refuses to kill and
take someone's life from them
on top of the fact that he doesn't
really want to become god that much
however there are 12 other candidates
and as such each of them has their own
twisted morally ambiguous idea of what
god should be
like light
views on how humanity should proceed in
the future what they would do as god him
or herself
a path that inevitably
leads to conflict
the latter two of the themes mentioned
by oba and obata the merits of modern
society and life vs death however
emerge as certainly the most important
themes in platinum end
after all all 13 of our main cast
whether they act as villains or
protagonists are all people who were
saved from attempted suicide
just as the death note rejuvenates the
board genius within light yagami this
story also follows these people all
coming to grips with a life that though
only minutes ago made you suicidal
suddenly gives you the chance to become
all-powerful
but an aspect that is distinct from
death note is that platinum specifically
focuses mostly on suicide and the fact
that japan is incredibly overworked and
leads to suicide in many youths
a topic that i've mentioned and
discussed many times on my channel in
this video and this video
but even this attempt to stray away from
death note ironically comes full circle
because where death note is centralized
around a character who is willing to
kill anyone so that he can reach the top
platinum end focuses on a person who was
only ever willing to kill himself
even the parts of platinum end that
distinguish itself from death note make
itself an individual manga still act as
a form of yin and yang to death note it
is never completely separate
the first arc of platinum end what i
foresee being the first season of the
anime if it goes at a pace of around one
chapter per episode for 24 to 26 total
is incredible
it is drenched in mystery as mirai tries
to hide his identity among all of these
god candidates who may use it for good
or evil
and just as light and l battle in a
constant back and forth to discover each
other's identities in the first half of
death note
mirai must also outplay a conniving
villain that will do anything and kill
anyone to become god
but along with suicide platinum ends
most distinguishable trait what really
elevates the manga above all else is the
power system of god candidates
this is definitely one of the best parts
of this manga the arrows and angels with
a different ability to have wings and
red arrows versus white ones you won't
get what i'm saying if you haven't read
it but take my word for it
it really stands out and is used in ways
that i would expect from the minds
behind death note more so than just
controlling everyone to fall in love
with him or killing any opponents
instantly there are limitations and
rules in place that mirai discover and
that he must work around and that the
rest of the candidates must as well
but even where it's different it is
still reminiscent of the powerful death
note itself
without a name and a face you can do
nothing but if you do have both you can
order them to do things before death or
manipulate them in ways that allows for
endless creativity with the plot of the
story
mirai can't use his arrows to kill
someone unless he can see them likewise
light can only kill someone if he's seen
their face has witnessed them before
discovering one another's identities is
a crucial part of both of these stories
even the most intense action scenes in
platinum end which are far more common
in this manga than death note are really
driven by thought processes and dialogue
instead of the actual action more often
than not
there's a lot of text characters
thinking about their next move and
pitting their plan against someone else
who's been plotting something else
just like how a million thoughts race
through light's mind when he sits next
to elle at the introduction ceremony the
same goes for platinum end
it always feels psychological even if
it's as simple as a standoff between
potential gods
i think the first half of this series
just like in death note until the end of
the light vs l arc is a masterpiece
honestly it's amazing it did not fail in
using death note's strengths to its
advantage
despite all the similarities it still
feels incredibly unique and distinct as
a manga in the first half of this series
and i loved it
however though among the many great
traits that platinum end inherited from
death note ends writing
was also one hidden crucial factor that
was strong enough to break the system
entirely
a poor ending
the latter half of death note gets a lot
of hate because of the near arc which is
justified the show loses its momentum
the moment l disappears from the show
but unlike death note's finale which at
least brought a semblance of
satisfaction that light was brought to
justice even if l wasn't the one to do
it knowing the villain finally lost
the ending of platinum end has none of
that and is simply reduced to
philosophical ambiguity
what used to be an incredibly intriguing
cat and mouse chase between mirai and
the villains ends in about 10 chapters
of constant discussion and debate over
what the meaning of god is
the character's motives become blurred
conclusions and happy endings are rushed
the pieces that so beautifully recreated
what made death note amazing fell apart
and it's really a shame considering the
incredibly strong start the series had
the reputation of oba and obata as
mangakaz
but perhaps it was because platinum ends
attempted to live up to a legacy that
was simply too great to follow up
or perhaps because asking what if a god
of the new world was chosen
should have been buried with light
yagami himself
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-app show manga and
character analyses
you